I mean,
I frankly do feel that the,
uh,
the Europeans have a much more mature
overall
outlook on,
uh,
on this issue.
Um,
most people that I know anyway,
who were brought up in Europe,
uh,
were brought up with a little bit of
water blended with wine when they were
in their teens finally with a little bit
of wine at the dinner table,
you know,
when they were in their late teens and
by the time they hit 18,
it's not a big deal anymore.
And it's really in countries that,
uh,
that don't have as mature and outlook on
the issue that tend to have problems
with binge drinking,
et cetera.
I mean,
there can be,
I can see good arguments on either side,
but I mean,
I was responsible.
I,
I went through this weird period where I
was 18 and I was legal and then I became
illegal when they changed the,
uh,
when they changed it to 21.
And then I went back to being legal
again.
Like,
you know,
two years later I was in this weird kind
of a limbo thing.
And,
you know,
I think that I was responsible when I
was younger,
um,
you know,
you're going to,
uh,
I mean,
I,
I don't want to bring up to sort of,
you know,
all the classic,
uh,
you know,
well,
if you can go and fight in a war and you
can't have a beer,
all those things,
it's a complicated issue.
But I just do think that rather than
looking at it from a historical point of
view,
which I think is often the case that
people take a calmer longview
recognizing that,
uh,
that the enjoyment of alcoholic
beverages is a part of,
you know,
human humanity.
That's,
that's,
that's part of what we're,
we're all about buying large as human
beings.
I mean,
we've,
uh,
people believe that we went from a
hunter gatherer existence to a settled
agricultural existence in order to have
enough grain to make beer.
You know,
it is central to the human experience
and you know,
I think it's a,
you know,
and it,
and it's healthy for you.
I mean in moderation.
And it's better for you than not having
it.
So if,
you know,
if you really want to bring people up
properly,
you know,
teach them how to eat properly and teach
them how to drink properly.
You know,
I mean,
if you wanna,
if you want to ban something that's
going to,
you know,
uh,
caused a lot of problems,
you could say,
well,
let's band butter,
you know,
or let's ban.
I mean,
if you wanted to look at the overall
cost of the population,
but better
I teach people how to cook,
how to eat and how to live well.
Oh No,
there are alcoholics and you weren't
quite sure,
you know,
I mean unfortunately,
I mean alcoholism is a disease.
It is a problem,
uh,
just as overeating as a disease.
Um,
I mean beer essentially is food and
people are going to,
uh,
are going to abuse all sorts of foods in
different ways and whether this involves
your,
you know,
eating this and that and,
and growing to be,
you know,
a 400 lbs and,
and not being functional or,
you know,
it's a,
an alcohol problem.
All of these things are going to be
problems across the board and society.
I think you can take a more mature
outlook on it as a society and not look
at it as whether,
again,
it's,
you know,
it's eating or it's a alcohol.
Is it a moral problem or you know,
is it really teaching people how to
handle themselves in a world that my
hands everything to you on a platter and
says,
well,
here it is for you to consume.
And I think that,
uh,
you know,
um,
the Europeans have a better outlook on
it,
but there are by no means perfect.
Yeah,
well,
I can't say that I can answer a question
like that,
uh,
so quickly,
but I'm reminded of a,
of a,
uh,
Francois Mitterrand last meal,
which I think lasted about two days,
you know,
and had sort of every little,
order lawns and,
and whatever else,
and all of his friends around him.
Uh,
uh,
and the,
the,
the greatest,
uh,
the greatest risks that you can be
broad.
I mean,
I've had,
I've had beers as old as 18,
69,
which are unbelievable.
You know,
I,
I would be gathering up things for,
for years,
for,
for such an occasion,
so,
um,
and like me to,
I would,
I would make it that meal last for like
two or three days and say,
okay,
then that's that.
So it's not a question I get a,
I can answer quickly,
but I can,
I can assure you that it would be
awfully good.